we found this I wanted to just talking
to you just show a photo like okay
here's the here's the cast here's to you
and Tom Lennon this is the only photo we
could find of the two of you it's a big
hit sitcom on a major Network yeah why
are there no other photos just this one
photo of the two of you I'm not that big
a fan of photo shoots why well I had I
had an interesting experience a ways
back this is a ways back ways back okay
back when I was on the friendship show
I remember the friendship right
friendship show I think the kids call it
friends yeah yes we did a we did a photo
shoot with the cast of friends in the
cast of ER and a bunch of supermodels Oh
swimsuit models yeah and we were in kind
of close proximity to one another for a
few hours early on a Saturday morning
yeah and I got home Saturday afternoon
probably around 1:00 right I was a
little because of the proximity a little
how do I say it Randy
you were Randy you were I was you were
was healing I was horny you're horny you
were feeling horny because yeah you were
around supermodels oximeter right you
want a jerk ass the ER yeah
cast more supermodels - yeah yeah Noah
Wyle I'll do that - yeah real horned up
but there was no woman in my life at the
time so I decided I was gonna take care
of my little problem by watching some
porn right right sure you're with me are
you out in town so this is back in the
day when there were DVDs right not no
internet right no sliced bread
no no no just DVD this is the early
1990s this is all right 1995 yeah so I
decide to watch this movie and I put it
in the DVD and I want to take my time
with it
no you know it's been a big morning yeah
I want to take my time with it right so
I'm watching this thing for about a half
an hour oh yeah
congratulations yeah must've had a real
good story
yeah parts of it were was really
interesting yeah yeah so I'm watching
this film and then on comes the scene
with like 20 women doing unspeakable
things to each other right
on the on the TV yeah right and
everything you know ends and I wrap up
everything and it's all finished and I
don't know about should accomplish
should accomplish anything and I don't
know about you but once you're done
you're done right you need to that movie
to come right off yeah that movie has to
be off yeah it's perplexing to me how
something so wonderful can be so
terrible just two seconds later yeah it
reminds me of the the hot towels you get
on airplanes there's so great for like
three seconds disgusting rags after you
retrieved by salad tongs yeah yeah yeah
you're right right right so you had this
sublime moment it's fantastic finish
then you just want this pan off the I
want to turn it off so I grab the remote
control and I press power and it doesn't
shut off oh and it won't go off and I
don't want to stand up and go across the
room because I I want to go sleep yes
pretty much I just want to sleep yeah so
but it won't go off and I'm still
hearing it and seeing it then I want no
part of it anymore I'm done I'm finished
it's arcing now yeah suppose to me out
it's going it's ghosting me out now yeah
I had a feeling I could tell by the look
on your face so I decide what I'm gonna
do is I'll just turn the volume down and
then I'll go to sleep right right so I
press volume on the TV and I can see the
little nozzle go to zero on the wall
unit thing but I can still hear it and
I'm like what is going on what the hell
is happening and then I remember that
the night before I'd gone out into my
backyard with a glass of wine and
listened to music and then I realized
that for the last hour I've been
blasting a porno out of my door
remember that all the way down into the
San Fernando Valley this is one o'clock
in the afternoon you have you kids are
riding bikes around
they're dogs it was terrible I move
thank you
good god alright my apologize way you
won't get your picture taken to top oh
okay you never know what's gonna happen